- The Britney Spears conservatorship case
keeps getting more interesting
and more interesting.
Most recently, her
longtime manager has left
and he was followed
by her longtime court-appointed
lawyer, Samuel Ingram.
Now there are times when
a lawyer must resign
from representing their client,
but that probably doesn't apply here.
Things like your client
has asked you to do things
that are illegal
or you're a witness in
the actual case itself.
What's more likely here is that Ingram,
based on the notoriety from this case
and a slew of articles
that don't paint him in a
particularly great light,
feels that he can no
longer represent Spears.
And there may or may not
be anything untoward here.
Now in a case where a
lawyer wants to withdraw,
they generally have to get
approval from the court.
The court has to make
sure that this withdrawal
doesn't prejudice their client.
So ironically, we'll see both Brittany
and her lawyer in court.